Alexandr levia dev likes being in the
spotlight he used to be a Secret Service
Officer today he's one of Russia's
richest businessmen in a restaurant in
Moscow Liberty EV is launching his new
book in it he denounces the corruption
of the Russian elite but the
multi-millionaire is making headlines
for another reason
his supposed interference in brexit with
him but I know him may be generous
friends with him jenya is leather devs
son Evgeny he played host to British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson then the
foreign minister but his villa in Italy
when was the last time you met Boris
Johnson two or three years ago but I
think in total I've met him more than 10
times we wanted to know more about a
party at your Italian villa it was his
birthday but I myself didn't see Johnson
there he was tired and just relaxing
what do you want me to say that I saw
him or not either way I did not talk to
him your son when was the last time he
saw Johnson I don't know ask him
yourself
they've been friends for years did your
son contribute money to the
Conservatives he owns newspapers that
could theoretically influence people but
I doubt he's done that British
journalists are hard to influence I'm
sure my son didn't donate money to the
conservative or Labour Party or anyone
else for that matter
come on you shooting directly what about
you just leave kidding I can't afford to
do that so where are these suspicions
coming from this is fake news written by
the Guardians they want to compromise
Boris so that koban can become the next
prime minister of course with a little
help from the KGB the British media is
convinced that Lebedev supported Boris
Johnson and his party they point to a
parliamentary investigation whose
results should have been published three
weeks ago let's just wait until the
results are official I've demanded they
have published immediately I want to
know exactly what was written before I
comment on it the British government has
pushed back publication by a month now
the controversial report is set to come
out in December
and ew0 Rochette oh who filed that
report joins me now from Moscow good to
see you Yuri what exactly is Alexander
Lebedev accused off well mr. Lebedev is
reported to have interference indirectly
in the brexit campaign how exactly is
unclear as the British newspaper The
Sunday Times
however names him among other Russians
who allegedly co-financed breaks it he
would have been involved either as the
owner of two newspapers and the TV
station in the UK or through his son he
Afghani we saw him this in my report now
who invited British Prime Minister
Johnson to a private party in Italy the
name Lebedev will most likely be one of
the nine names of the Russians who
reportedly are going to appear in a
previously unpublished report by the
British intelligence services he's
denied the accusations Yuri but how
credible is he well honestly I have to
say that Alexander Liberty is a
comfortable target for allegations of
this kind because he himself used to be
a member of the KGB the secret services
here in Russia 20 years ago because he
himself worked as a diplomat at the
Russian embassy in London and because he
later became a Rapala Titian here in
Russia and worked as a member of the
Russian parliament the Duma but he says
that he was that was all a long time ago
and Lebedev has long been a business man
and not a politician anymore and his
argument in every discussion I have had
with him is that he himself has been a
victim of the intelligence services
however his business was targeted he has
even published a book on corruption in
Russian elites and in his view that
should free him from any accusations of
being close to the Russian state Yuri as
you mentioned he is not the only person
facing accusations so overall what is
your assessment did Russia medal in the
brexit campaign that's the one million
dollar question I think the British
Secret Service's have to find out and
convincingly prove Russian involvement
but
it's clear that we live in a time of
total mistrust everything began with the
allegations of Russian meddling in the
u.s. election campaign and in Russia
such allegations always provoke a
tit-for-tat response the Russians have
now even established two parliamentary
commissions here in Moscow to
investigate potential foreign influence
in the zero internal of eternal affairs
this issue of so-called foreign
interference is extremely hyped here in
Russia and these new potential legations
from the UK are no different that they
are a big news here but we have to wait
for the report from London to be able to
see beyond the hype
all right well bringing us the view from
Moscow DW rochette oh thanks Yuri